foreign
asked me to read a book
Christmas Story and so I brought what is
one of my House's favorite Christmas
books by Mike Reese and by
my wife is a children's literature
person
um and but I share this with her David
catrow one of our favorite illustrators
the book is called Merry unchristmas
it's about a family who has Christmas
every day of the year and it's such a
burden and they get one day off a year I
love this book and I was gonna read it
but then fun ruiner.com
net.org here
and I won't name their name Chris said
that we have to have copyright to
everything so we can't read the book so
go buy it I want to support Mike I have
no relationship to this dude but I think
this book's fantastic and the
illustrations are incredible by David
um so we are going to the public domain
and we're gonna read with some
commentary
a few people's favorite Christmas Story
it was the night before Christmas
[Music]
it was the night before Christmas went
all through the house
not a creature was stirring not even a
mouse
the stockings were hung by the chimney
with care and tape in hopes that Saint
Nicholas
soon would be there not eating the
grapes
bad rhyming the children were all snug
in their beds nestled all snug in their
beds while visions of
sugar plums
and cigarettes depending on what kind of
kid you're raising danced in their heads
and mama and her kerchief
mama is that I use all you sleep in is
it kerchief
um in my eye and my cap man this this
story got a little bit
about whoa
had settled down for a long winter's nap
they've been drinking
when out on the lawn there arose such a
clatter
was it somebody doing drugs and another
Mad Hatter no I sprang from the bed to
see what was the matter
evidently had time to get dressed
because he was previously only wearing a
cap
away to the window I flew like a flash
I brought some clothes so no one would
see my tore open the shutters and threw
up the sash
the moon on the breast of the new fallen
snow gave the luster of the midday to
objects below
so it's like a freshman at College
trying to write a research paper like
there's so much easier ways to say this
when what to my wondering eyes should
appear
drugs no but a miniature sleigh an eight
tiny reindeer
had I done too much shrooms I asked
myself
slick with a little old driver so Lively
and quick no I knew in a moment it must
be Saint Nick
more rapid than Eagles his courser as
they came and he whistled and shouted
and called him by name
now Dasher now dancer now Prancer and
Vixen
on comment on Cupid on donder and
Blitzen
to the top of the porch to the top of
the wall
now dash away Dash away Dash away all
at which point all the reindeer look at
each other and like what the crabs he
talking about like what why is he just
yelling our names and telling us to go
to the porches and walls what what is
happening
but they're just deer they just do what
they're told you know as dry leaves
before the wild hurricane fly now we're
getting into weather issue this whole
thing is just getting off the rails when
they meet with an obstacle mount to the
sky
for those of you who run into obstacle
mounts in the sky you've done far too
much drugs that day it's time to stop
it's time to stop go to bed reset
so up to the Housetop the coursers they
flew with the sleigh full of toys in
Saint Nicholas too
and then in a twinkling I heard on the
roof
[Laughter]
one of the reindeer had taken it just
kidding the Prancing and pawing of each
little hoof
as I drew in my head and was turning
around down the chimney St Nicholas came
with a bound
and he was quite round
and he made a sound like a basset hound
with a frown he was dressed all in fur
dude that's what I'm talking about
what's up ladies
from his head to his foot and his
clothes are all tarnished with ashes and
soot
I think that's because he was rolling a
little 20 twin twin but that's just me a
bundle of toys he had flung on his back
and he looked like a peddler just
opening his pack
here's just a random bunch of pictures
and the dog wagging his tail
way to go here Fido
terrible guard dog
his eyes how they twinkled his dimples
how merry his cheeks were like roses his
nose like a cherry
can we just stop this whole story is
madness it's just Madness look at this
photo this guy
let's just rolled up on somebody's
recliner with feet out just chilling
arms back
he's doped up the dog kicked his feet
off he's just chilling and I guess he
lit the fire back that makes sense
his droll little mouth was drawn up like
a bow and the beard on his chin was as
white as the snow
the stump of a pipe he held in his teeth
he's smoking inside great neighbor very
cool
and the smoke it encircled his head like
a wreath
puff puff give
he had a broad face in a round little
belly
That Shook like when he laughed like a
bowl full of jelly now this book's just
getting mean it's just mean he needs to
call into the show people talking bad
about him
he was chubby and plump a right Jolly
Old elf and I laughed when I saw him in
spite of myself
can you imagine somebody breaking it
into your house and then
you see them you're not scared you just
laugh at their physical appearance I
think the author of this book should
call the show because he needs an
attitude adjustment he's rude he's mean
he's mean a wink of his eye and a Twist
of his head
laughs
I worry to myself am I soon to be dead
soon gave me to know I had nothing to
dread he spoke not a word but went
straight to his work and filled all of
the stockings then turned with a jerk
maybe it's meth and not smoking
and laying his finger up inside of his
nose a side of his nose and giving a nod
up the chimney he rose
he sprang to his sleigh to his team gave
a whistle
and if the away they all flew like the
down of a Thistle and let's be honest we
all know how the down of a thistle flies
this is why this this right here why are
our kids so anxious because of this
but I heard him exclaim as he drove out
of sight
I got all your crap Merry Christmas to
all and to all
a good night
Merry Christmas to you all everybody I
love you